My name is Dr Jenifer Zeligs. And I am the director of Training and Research
for a Special Program here at Cal State University. Which functions like a
teaching aquarium for students from all over the world. To come and learn about
how to use animal behavior modification to take the best possible care of
animals. And work with them in zoo and aquarium environments, as well as in
research facilities.
>> So, and you're writing a book, as you're an expert in the field. What was that
book?
>> it's called Animal Training 101, the complete and practical guide to the art
and science of behavior modification. And I hope it'll be a good guide for
people who are interested in animal training and behavior in general.
>> Wonderful. So, do you use the ABCs of operant conditioning in your work?
>> Yes, so the ABCs of operant conditioning is one of the classic ways that people
explain the idea of how behavior is developed. And A stands for antecedent, B
behavior, and C consequences. This is the method by which behavior is created,
whether I'm doing it intentionally, or whether it's happening on its own in the
natural world. The antecedent to trained behavior is a cue. The antecedent in
the process of training is usually a type of, of conditioning technique that
you'd use, for example you'll see us using targets. This is a thing that we can
use to cause and create the behavior that we then want to see, which is the B.
And then the C, the consequence, is the reward, the reinforcement, that
influences the animal to want to do that behavior again in the future. Another
type of consequence can be a punisher, so there's two types of, well there's
actually 3 types of consequences. Reinforcer, which increases the frequency of
the behavior. Neutral, which does nothing to the frequency of behavior. And
punisher, which decreases the frequency of behavior.